we begin with the breaking news today in
the special council's Russia probe 13
Russians and three Russian entities have
been charged with an elaborate plot to
interfere with our 2016 presidential
election Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen seen made the announcement earlier
and there was a lot to break down chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has all the details Catherines
well thanks Kimberly I was at that news
conference at main justice as Justice
Department headquarters here in
Washington when they released this 37
page indictment the charges are against
13 Russian nationals three Russian
organizations for allegedly defrauding
the United States but specifically the
illegal use of social media to interfere
in the election in this particular case
to support the candidacy of Donald Trump
and to disparage Hillary Clinton one of
the key things we learned today is that
this operation really predates the
confirmation of either of the leading
candidates in the presidential election
it began in 2014 which is when it was
seeded in st. Petersburg Russia by an
individual who was closely aligned with
the Russian President but then it really
kicked off and picked up steam in mid
2016 when they took about five dozen
people and specifically tasked them with
the Russian interference in our election
here's the Deputy Attorney General from
earlier today there is no allegation in
this indictment that any American was a
knowing participant there is no
allegation in the indictment that the
charge conduct altered the outcome of
the 2016 election I've read the
indictment twice now and it's important
to note that anyone who is connected to
the Trump campaign is unidentified in
the indictment they're referred to
simply as members volunteers or
supporters of the Trump campaign since
that announcement today the president
has put out a tweet and it reads in part
Russia started their anti US campaign in
2014 long before I announced that I
would run for president the results of
the election were not impacted the Trump
campaign did nothing wrong no collusion
the Deputy Attorney General made clear
today that at least on this digital
piece they found the Russian
farrance but they did not find any
American was willingly cooperating with
the Russians to amplify that effort but
the Deputy Attorney General was silent
on other outstanding issues that may
remain in the Russia case Kimberly all
right Catherine thank you so much
welcome tremendous developments today
you know Dana in a way kind of
unexpected that this was gonna come out
today quite revealing and a number of
people indicted what do you what's your
take away well a couple things one it
was such a surprise and partly that's
because while there are lots of leaks in
other parts of the government the Bob
Buller investigation it pretty is
airtight like nobody knew what it was
coming in fact when the press conference
was announced it was going happening at
1:15 pretty much nobody knew what it was
about some people speculated that rod
Rosen Stein was going to resign
obviously that didn't happen and
actually today's development probably
ensures that rod Rosenstein is not in
any danger of being fired anytime soon I
think it also proves that Mitt Romney
was right remember in the campaign when
he said to President Obama that the
Russians were a geopolitical enemy and
Obama dismissed it turns out that in
2014 this is when all of this started we
do know that everybody's been saying
that the Russians try to do this all of
it all the time so it's possible that
maybe the Obama administration was
monitoring it in 2014 and didn't think
it was that big a deal but it certainly
ramps up and as Juan has said before
there is frustration on behalf of the
Democrats that the president seemed to
not have done more at the time I think
it's a solid indictment I also think
that it proves that Russian meddling was
not a hoax mm-hmm and so because the
global threat hearing that happened this
week was there was a focus on this about
what's happening in 2018 hopefully now
and the president says in his statement
today or the press secretary statement
that this is a time for everybody to
work together to figure out a way to
push back against the Russians also for
those of you Twitter bots in st.
Petersburg or tweeting me during the
election I could just Oh Mike I could
say it but I won't I won't but I really
it really done it was 77 blame to go
through yeah all of anybody who was a
targeted and part of the campaign are
reporting on the campaign considered
influential was just absolutely
barded by these jerks all right well now
they've gotten to the bottom of it so
there's been some expeditious justice
with these indictments Gregg's want to
talk to you a sec about you know the
president coming out right away with his
own communication strategy in terms of
tweeting about it and putting the the
postmark back to 2014 saying look this
does not invalidate the credibility the
authenticity legitimacy of my campaign
my election as the United States
President and this predated anything
with as it relates to my campaign yeah
it's interesting to see who's how the
goal posts are being moved the people
celebrating this pretending that
meddling is collusion is being dishonest
anybody who says this is proof of
anything beyond meddling is lying
look Russians meddling is their baseball
that's their pastime as somebody married
pyon medley that's someone married to a
Russian I know this is the case and she
happens to be in Moscow right now I
don't know if that's a coincidence she's
getting a quickie divorce but here's the
deal they coordinated rallies to support
Trump and they coordinated rallies to
protest Trump so they're like that that
weird character in a soap opera that's
trying to like in break up a married
couple and sow discord among them and
make their lives ruined that's in but
we've known this is what they do they
are the globe's trolls and the thing is
we have to be very stoic about this
because every time we get emotional
about this stuff and we have been
emotional about this for a year
screaming at each other about whether
the Russians did this and were we
involved where we colluding they were
winning this was the whole point
that's why they supported Trump and then
that's why they supported the protesters
that's why they would go after you and
then that's why they start putting out
emails doing it forever so the thing is
yeah I mean who would remember what's
the name rocky and bullwinkle who were
their villains Natasha
Boris so we knew this even when we were
kids my point is this when we allowed
them to separate us that was a problem
and it's a problem we can't do to them
because they only have a single ideology
which is being Russian we have they
don't really have election yeah exactly
we have a bifurcated 99.9 was right
the bottom line is we have we are
plagued by team sport politics that
divides on every issue and they know
that so they know how to pick the teams
and have them go at each other just like
a soap opera villain I almost admire it
you almost feel I really appreciate
insanity Shaun Boris okay so Jessie what
do you make of today's development and
the communication piece from the
President and from the press secretary
well he said there's no collusion and it
doesn't look like there's any witting
collusion and that was very specific for
people that are still saying that there
may have been collusion in the
indictment I read the indictment it was
a little boring not very sexy but at the
end it said that's what the dossier is
one of this emailed a Trump campaign
official three times offering locations
in Florida to have a rally it does not
even mention if the Trump campaign
official emailed back so that's all you
have they communicated unwittingly it
could have been one-way communication
I'm not going to say that there was no
collusion yet I mean there's still no
evidence of collusion according to this
indictment so what they did was
basically information warfare they set
up a bunch of bots it was only in the
tens of millions of dollars not that
expensive and they buy a bunch of ads on
Facebook and when you think of how
sophisticated it was it wasn't that
sophisticated it was rudimentary they
would hire a person to dress up like
Hillary put a little blonde wig on and
wear a prison jumpsuit and stand at a
trump rally so when I was you know I
asked one of these people you want to do
an interview and she said yet and now I
understand why she was paid - your point
- this was not to be called to testify
this was pro Trump for a while and it
was pro Bernie Sanders for a while and
it was anti Hillary and then it became
anti Trump after the election so the
point was to sow discord and that was
effective but I would say the Democrats
are helping the Russians so discord
because of the dossier because of the
constant accusations of treason and if
you boil it all up I would say
dossier and these crazy allegations and
the billion dollars Hilary spent on
advertising and the biased mainstream
media propaganda was much more
influential than a few hundred Twitter
BOTS and a few silly rallies held in New
York City after the election all right
one let me guess you see it differently
oh yeah I do I think that we have a
situation here where we don't know the
end I mean this is clearly still in
midstream in terms of what Muller is
doing but I would say that as we heard
from rod Rosenstein there's no direct
evidence of any complicity by any
specific person in the Trump campaign we
don't know they said at times for
example you had people in the Trump
campaign who would retweet a lot of the
efforts that were being made by the
Russians but again unknowingly and then
you had people who were suggesting to
them hey target these swing states go
after Virginia look at Colorado etc but
again maybe not knowing that you're
dealing with Russians who are
interfering the big point that I would
register here is a take away is that
President Trump has said repeatedly that
this is such fake this is fake this is a
fraud as there was no Russian
interference in this election well now
we know they're definitely the
intelligence community has said it
robert muller has said it we've got an
indictment there was Russian
interference in the 20s you know what
he's saying that he's referring to
collusion so you can you can have your
meddling that's what he's saying yeah
but I wasn't in what he said you know
what he meant you meant he said I wasn't
involved I wasn't involved I had nothing
to do with this we won fair and square
that's we saying the fact the fact that
Russians help us win is a hoax is what
he's saying that's not true because
Russians did help him win because what
they're saying is discussions Russians
were promoting propagandistic in a fair
spec to not affect the election it did
affect the election it affected our
conversation it affected the way we talk
so now you're broadening the word effect
even if you even when we think about you
were saying oh you know they only spent
so much money remember they're really
behind the hacking of Hillary Clinton's
campaign Podesta all that and spreading
of all the rumors that get picks up by
mainstream media that followed the whole
business about her emails and all that
that's all amplified by what the
Russians were
but on a fun level I disagree with you
Jesse I think it is a fun 37 page read
because they've got some you know you
talk about dressing up like Hillary put
put her in the cage lock her up I think
that's pretty hilarious and then they
got this thing about if you're a woke
black person Clinton is Satan and we
can't vote for the lesser of two devils
and they've also big supporters of Jill
Stein and who I think might be in some
trouble herself but I think that when
you look at the way that they approach
our election and us as an American
people they think that we are kind of
dumb cops well no you know the reason is
one is what I said they don't have the
vulnerabilities that we have there's no
way we can do this now we can't go you
know mess with Ukraine and do things
like that and by the way we do do those
things so they look at us and they go
and they I have a feeling that they look
at what they're doing as defensive
maneuvers finding out things that
protect them which is you know what a
lot of people do not condoning it but
the interesting thing to me is I grew up
in the 70s and I remember how cold
warriors were so mocked by the left
academia media Democrats over the
Russian threat when they were eight
times larger than they were now and it's
so refreshing to see all these Democrats
coming out and saying how evil this evil
empire is it's a little too late I'd
like to add to that because under
Obama's watch you had Russia invade
Ukraine you had Russia set up bases in
Syria now military bases and propped up
Assad when they gassed their own people
they shipped weapons and anti-aircraft
missiles to Iran and Obama didn't do
that much he wasn't that tough on Russia
and all of a sudden from 2014 until 2017
a few hundred Russians with maybe ten to
twenty million dollars did a little
disinformation warfare during the
election called Hillary names
and dressed up like Hillary and you know
retweeted a bunch of propaganda and all
of a sudden now there's indictments for
four years later and everyone's crying
like it's a new Cold War I just feel
like when we really needed the Democrats
to help Republicans fight the Cold War
they were nowhere to be found
you start and they mocked messing around
with Hillary then it's like you know you
got to fight these guys nevertheless
there will be there will be a
geopolitical fallout and also in areas
like Syria wait till I get home yeah
well we'll see what happens
good luck to you Greg I know he's on her